[Music]
and so began a dazzling new age of an
independent britain
and my goodness was it tasty
starting 2021 with a lovely brexit
breakfast
after 48 years of wedded bliss the uk
is out on its own we saw the first ferry
leave post-brexit britain's shores cross
the channel
and dock in calais and while the first
lorry to enter the euro tunnel after
midnight might have been given a
friendly go-ahead
for others trying to cross from wales
into ireland it wasn't such a pleasant
bienvenue
wild has been quiet in hollyhat so far
today the port authority indicates that
six freight loads
bound for ireland have had to be turned
away due to not have the correct
references
but being newly bogged down in red tape
isn't the only thing
dampening the post-brexit spirit anger
regret and bitterness are particularly
strong
in scotland with the majority feeling
that they'd be better off
back with brussels scotland will be back
soon europe
keep the light on some would say this is
the first stage of grief
denial but with support for scottish
independence
rising by the day and hitting 58
in recent weeks there's now a fear that
breaking with brussels
might well cost the uk its 300
year union with scotland so brexiteers
might be
reveling triumphantly in their newfound
independence
now but there won't be any victory laps
when they're left with a
divided kingdom no wonder then that
people are
nervous about the road ahead i would say
as a young person
my focus has mainly been on money travel
in europe and education and how that
opportunity might be taken away from us
very very soon
the uk has given away a lot and got very
little in return
it's just going to make life a lot more
complicated the biggest um
impact for me is just going to be not
traveling and
really not feeling like i am a european
anymore
i feel like that's just been kind of
ripped away which is heartbreaking
while some are nervous others just can't
let the past go in fact
they want a rewrite the campaign for
britain to rejoin europe starts at
midnight
in the meantime hundreds of thousands
are hoping the eu will forgive them
and hand on over a pity passport
while others have gone to extremes doing
a deep dive into family archives praying
that they can find some long-lost french
german italian it really doesn't matter
great great aren't three times removed
whom they've never met but who might
well be their lifeline to visa for
travel
if i understand it correctly i am french
my mother was born in france her mother
was totally french
as was her grandfather so for me it is
about reclaiming what i already have
and that makes me very happy i will
always be a european
that's for sure nothing like brexit
bojo's own father
jumping ship to instill confidence in
these uncertain times
but boris isn't too bothered in fact
he's rather pleased with himself
this is an amazing moment for this
country
we have our freedom in our hands
and it is up to us to make the most of
it
while it might be a freedom fountain and
boris's hands
but as restlessness disillusionment and
division in britannia grow
there's a sense that the only thing
britons are left holding
are empty promises
you